[Musique]
lors du spin casting ils étaient 96
candidats à vouloir décrocher le prix du
challenge des créateurs
une sélection qui emmène les meilleurs
d'entre eux à la finale qui s'est
déroulée à la villa du département
je me suis dit un événement qui consacre
sept créateurs d'entreprise pour leur
projet d'insertion professionnelle et de
leur dynamisme
une finale qui met à l'honneur les
créateurs d'entreprises et le travail
mené par le département et ses
partenaires alors que l'utilité
départementale organise
vous savez cette 20e édition pour
féliciter et encourager d'entreprise
cette 21e édition a désormais ses sept
lauréats près de l'insertion
bernadette rayapin création d'emplois
idriss rivière spree de la start up et
issia pause aboudou prix/produit pays
martin potins prix du jury david vacarme
creed et l'innovation matière chariot
prix de la performance cette nathalie
noir remercie en premier je citerai
olivier josé
[Musique]
ma famille qui m'accompagne et puis je
remercie également le département
d'organiser ce type de challenge parce
que c'est une reconnaissance un 21e
anniversaire qui une nouvelle fois aura
mise en valeur le savoir-faire pays
[Musique]